once upon a time Jessica Alba seemed
poised for superstardom tearing up both
television and movies with a series of
hits that had fans screaming for more
beautiful talented popular what didn't
Alba seem to have going for her but
instead of an unstoppable career she
suddenly dropped off the map here's a
look at why Hollywood won't cast Jessica
Alba anymore The Invisible Woman Alba's
biggest claim to fame is probably her
role in 2005 Sin City where she shared
the screen with a huge ensemble cast
that included mega stars like Bruce
Willis and Clive Owen Sin City proved to
be a massive hit
but her reign at the top was incredibly
brief because just a couple months later
Fantastic Four came out though it was a
modest box-office success
critics savage the film and the
experience of making it caused Alba to
re-evaluate whether she even wanted to
be an actress at all after director Tim
story berated her for actually acting
too well during a crying scene instead
he wanted to actually add tears in
post-production using CGI Alba told Elle
quote it all got me thinking am I not
good enough are my instincts and my
emotions not good enough do people hate
them so much that they don't want me to
be a person am I not allowed to be a
person in my work and so I just said it
I don't care about this business anymore
and quote that may explain why Alba
hasn't made a memorable movie since
exotic Hollywood hasn't always had the
greatest track record when it comes to
casting diversity so you may not be
surprised to hear that Alba's choice of
roles has been limited by her heritage
she told PopSugar that she wasn't
considered Caucasian enough to play
white roles or Hispanic enough to play
latina roles then when I did start you
know getting a lot of
and auditioning they couldn't figure out
my ethnicity so they just call I would
always go up for exotic so much for show
business being color blind the bomb
squad
it's safe to say that Albus films don't
always get good reviews or often or like
ever in fact of the 29 movie she's made
that have enough reviews to qualify for
a rotten tomato score only three of them
have a fresh rating which is kind of
incredible mathematically speaking you'd
expect random chance would give her at
least a few decent roles and over the
years Alba herself has been singled out
for being particularly bad in those
films landing Razzie nominations in 2006
2008 2009 and 2011 when she finally won
four worst Supporting Actress which is
understandable given even she seems a
little confused at times just what roles
she's supposed to be playing we also
both know that I'm not just anybody in
my Dumbledore no Jessica
this is Dumbledore business before
pleasure after becoming disillusioned
with the film industry Alba turned her
attention in other directions such as
raising her two children in 2008 after
using a popular detergent specifically
for kids one of her children developed a
painful rash the incident inspired Alba
to found the honest company which makes
affordable environmentally-friendly
non-toxic household goods the honest
company officially launched in 2011 and
by 2015 was valued at nearly two billion
dollars it has an Alban organic roses
though in 2016 the Wall Street Journal
accused the honest company of false
advertising and the company has faced
multiple lawsuits Alba chalks it up to
the downside of being a celebrity if an
organization wants to bring awareness to
their cause I'm an easy target and our
brand is an easy target don't call it a
comeback despite everything Alba has
been keeping her foot in the door by
appearing in smaller film roles and she
still has a large fan following so it's
not a matter of whether she can make a
comeback it's just a question of whether
she wants to be still
greenlit my passion project while she
has said in the past that she's open to
doing more movies in the future it seems
like it'll take the perfect film to
bring her out of semi-retirement in
other words don't call her Hollywood
she'll call you thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]